labour party in scotland yesterday
elected a new leader its fourth
permanent leader in less than six years
and osawa takes on the challenge of
trying to make labour competitive in
scotland again ahead of those
crucial elections in may where the snp
are expected to do
well well alessana joins us now from
glasgow thank you very much for being on
the program congratulations
on your victory now
labour's got a mountain good morning
thank you labour's got a mountain to
climb in scotland
how are you going to start climbing up
look i think the first part is to be
honest and say that
we have got a really bad position we're
in just now i'm not naive about the
scale of challenge
and that's why yesterday i thought it
was important to say directly
to the people of scotland that they've
not had the labour party they deserve
and at a time of rising inequality
injustice and division
we haven't been good enough and i
recognize that it's my job now to work
day and night to give people the labour
party
they deserve so we can build the country
we need and i actually think coming
through covered
we have the opportunity to focus on what
the people's priorities are
rather than the old arguments in the old
divisions
it's interesting isn't it because labour
does look quite different to how it did
a year ago
kierstama is very different from jeremy
corbyn of course and you're quite a
different air politician from richard
leonard
um do you think it's fair to say that
labour believes it needs to win from the
centre look i think it's
it's it's less that i think it's more
about looking outwards rather looking
inwards
recognizing that whatever divisions we
think might exist within our own
political party or indeed between our
political parties
they pale into insignificance compared
to the divisions and inequalities that
exist
in our society and we've got to reflect
scotland's future and i think the uk's
future and i think at times we haven't
done that
and you mentioned being a very different
leader i don't think that we've had a
leader that
a 37 year old from the west of scotland
that looks like me from
a muslim heritage that in itself i think
demonstrates a very different scotland
outward-looking scotland international
scotland i should also say that doesn't
say something about me that says
something great about
these people of scotland and and i want
to work with all our diverse communities
to rebuild the country that we love
of course a really big part of the
political landscape in scotland is this
question of
independence um if the snp win a
majority
in the elections that are coming up will
they have a mandate for a second
referendum
look i think the first thing to say in
that is there's a poll out today that
that shows that um
yes is not in the lead so we've heard a
lot about significant polls leading up
to this point
where yes i've been in the lead but i
would go further than that i actually
think it's of course it's for the
scottish people to choose
their own future but actually is it the
right thing to have a referendum
and i think coming through the
collective trauma of covet where we've
been separated from our families and our
loved ones
but we've actually come together like a
country like never before
the idea that we come through this and
go straight into a divisive referendum
campaign i just don't think is the right
thing
to do instead i think it's right that we
focus on rebuilding our country
because what people are worried about
right now is they're worried about their
loved ones staying safe they're worried
when they're going to get a vaccine
they're worried about if and when
they're going to go back to work
they're worried about their child's
education or mental health they're
worried about the planet we're going to
leave
our children our grandchildren they're
worried about the cancelled operations
or the failure to get a cancer diagnosis
because of a pause in the screening
program
these are all massive massive issues and
i would much rather we had political
leadership that focused on those issues
and tried to reunite our country rather
than divide our country again
and on that i actually don't think even
nicola sturgeon would be advocating a
referendum right now
but i think she's more focused on
healing the wounds in our political
party
than she is about healing the wounds in
the country and we will talk about some
of the
wounds as you say in the snp but just to
uh talk for
a bit more about scottish independence
in that referendum i totally understand
that you don't think now is the right
time for a referendum but if the snp win
a majority
in the elections will they have a
mandate for a second referendum i mean
they don't really hide their support for
do they they're called the scottish
national party
yeah they don't hide their support for
it but nicholas sergeant needs to decide
what people are voting on either they're
voting on pandemic record either they're
voting
voting on government record or they're
voting on whether they want to have
an independence referendum look i i
don't want to commentate about what
happens after me
we aren't um spectators we are
participants and i think this is the
challenge for us as a labour party
is if i believe in something i'm going
to argue for it so i don't believe
that independence is the right answer
for scotland coming through this
pandemic
i don't believe coming straight through
this pandemic and going to a referendum
campaign
is the right thing for us to do when our
entire focus should be on saving lives
and livelihoods
and rebuilding our country again and if
i don't believe in something i'm not
going to argue for it
instead what i say to people is let's
have enough
of the politicians trying to present you
with binary choices whether it is yes or
no or leave and remain
and forcing you to pick a side let's
instead look at what unites us as a
country
and focus on those issues in the next
parliament
okay um now a lot of attention has been
paid this week of course to alex simon's
committee appearance and nicolas
sturgeon's going to be giving evidence
next week
if the first minister is found to have
broken the ministerial code as alexander
alleges
should she resign
look i think it's important i think to
take the
political parties out of this and take
the personalities out of this
and go and go straight to the points of
principle the points of principle here
are
that two women were failed in terms of
their complaints how do we have a fair
complaints policy here in scotland
how do we respect the primacy of
parliament how do we respect
and not have the misuse of public funds
i think we should be separating the role
of
the person that is the legal adviser to
the scottish government not being the
person that also
leads prosecutions for us in scotland
and on the point of principle
directly on the question you ask if
there is a minister forget who the
minister is or which political party
they are from
if a minister is found to breach the
ministerial code i think people would
expect
that minister to resign that's what
nicola sergeant would say if it was a
labour politician a conservative
politician or a liberal democrat
politician
so let's take the party politics over as
a point of principle
so just be clear if nicolas sturgeon's
fans have broken the ministerial code
you think she should resign
well yes i think nikola serger herself
would say if an
opposition politician was in government
and they'd reach the ministerial code
that they would be expected to resign
let's take the party politics and the
personalities that have
disappointed principle and respecting
the office of first minister
are you a bit worried that uh the fact
that they have had this
extraordinary feud play out in public
and yet they're still
polling well above the other parties
above 50
it doesn't seem to have damaged them
well we've got to take part of the
responsibility for that i mean the
reality is we haven't had opposition
political parties that been on the pitch
in scotland and we haven't been the ones
to offer any kind of hope or change to
our country
so we've got to change that and i think
coming through this pandemic i don't
think we can go back to
the politics the way it was before i
don't think we can go back to the
economy the way it was before
i don't think people could credibly
believe that the conservatives can
deliver a recovery that works for
everyone
and reshapes our economy and i think the
snp
are so blinded by their one priority
that they can't be the ones that truly
bring our country back together and
rebuild it after covet
and that's why we need a credible labour
party that's why we need to get the
labour party back in the pitch
talking about the ideas that matter to
people the priorities that matter to
people
and therefore seeking to gain support in
the upcoming elections
okay just finally and many of our
viewers may just be being introduced to
you they may not know that much about
you so
to try and help them find out a bit more
about anasawa can you tell me something
interesting about yourself
something interesting about myself well
yesterday i was playing in the park with
my
uh my see that again sorry
so i said whatever you want throw the
delay on the on the line
whatever i want well i've i've got a
reception of a football manager
i was playing in the park yesterday my
kid and he gave me a big thumbs down
rather than a big thumbs up
live on camera and i used to be an nhs
dentist
and someone i'd say looks like me sounds
like me standing for election trying to
seek the people's support
and i think there's lots of interesting
things that we can have conversations
about on that one so